what causes much of the world's
conflicts well if you agree with these
guys they'd say religion is the catalyst
for almost all of the world's violence I
think faith based religion is the mother
lode of bad ideas people will kill each
other's children for ancient books and
caves and relics there is a logical
pathway leading from religion to the
committing of atrocities Sam Harris
Christopher Hitchens and Richard Dawkins
are considered to have launched a strain
of thought called new atheism it's a
small but incredibly vocal group but how
accurate are the new atheists in their
broad claims of our religion and its
role in global strife it's also the case
that people do violence on behalf of
nation-states and flags and kings and
oil and the list goes on and on
hey guys i'm omar and this sunday we're
talking about the new atheist their
problem with religion and how that
impacts how we talk about faith
there are many different types of
atheists atheism is the lack of belief
in the existence of a God or divine
power and it's been around forever but
in the United States the number of
people who say they're atheist has
doubled since 2007 a new political
movement among atheists burst onto the
scene in the years following 9/11 and
they were everywhere
I'm an atheist with respect to the
judeo-christian God we are absolutely at
war with Muslims and you as a
level-headed guy who understands
journalist Gary wolf coined the term New
Atheists a movement among non-believers
who are united by what they believe are
rationalist anti-god claims the new
atheists believe that religion threatens
progress and ultimately breeds conflict
they also believe that if religion were
eliminated many of the world's problems
would disappear they're very
confrontational as Professor bill
Kavanaugh
explains it's an atheist with a certain
kind of a polemical edge creating a
distance between people who believe and
people who supposedly don't believe so
the ideas that I have facts but you have
mere beliefs in fact the way the new
atheist aggressively challenged religion
is what they're most known for
they even mocked faith and believers
because if you believe something without
evidence then that justifies anything
but their ideas don't necessarily
represent those of most atheists the
vast majority of them 65% say they
rarely or never discuss their views on
religion with religious people and some
atheists like humanist chaplain Greg
Epstein see new atheist rhetoric as
problematic there are a lot of people in
this world who see religion as their
culture their community their family
their ancestors and when we openly mock
every aspect of it in a way that is very
likely to be interpreted as
disrespectful then we are driving a
wedge between ourselves and them writer
Luke Savage says new atheists use a
facade of rational arguments to
legitimize Western military
interventions there are people that see
a lot of illiberal and
anti-enlightenment tendencies in kind of
modern society and culture and foremost
among those is religion one of the new
atheist central arguments is that
religion is inherently violent they all
believe that religion is behind much of
the world's violence in both the past
and the present and the religion they
happen to be most critical of is this
law but we'll talk more about that later
right now let's discuss where new
atheists claim to get some of their
ideas the Enlightenment the
Enlightenment was a period between the
17th and 19th centuries where the idea
emerged that human beings didn't need an
institution like the church to live a
good moral life human rationality should
be at the forefront of that these ideas
emerge during a period when political
corruption and tyranny were rampant
across many European monarchies and they
were propped up by the church which many
even argue was used as an instrument of
oppression it takes on a particular sort
of polemical edge in the current context
because it's really establishes divide
between social orders in a lot of ways
one of the main critiques directed at
the New Atheists is that they examine
so-called religious violence in a vacuum
critics say their arguments completely
ignore the role that land resources
money and power playing getting two
sides to use violence as a means of
achieving their goals the New Atheists
also dismiss ignore and erase centuries
of history and simplistically pick
complicated conflicts as simply faith
versus reason we never go to war for a
single reason military historians tell
us that there are always multiple
factors involved military territorial
and above all economic as well as
political and social that's religious
scholar and former nun Karen Armstrong
and in her 2014 book fields of blood she
argues religion is used as much to
promote violence as it is a sanctuary
from violence this hasn't stopped new
atheists from having a list of go-to
conflicts that they repeatedly provide
as examples that religion is synonymous
with violence like the Crusades and then
in Ireland there were the troubles which
pitted Irish Catholics who wanted to
reunite Northern Ireland with the
Republic of Ireland against Irish
Protestants who were loyal to the United
Kingdom new atheist Christopher Hitchens
said it was a conflict where religion
spurred much of the violence which
resulted in more than 3,500 dead 400
years at for 400 years but in my own
country of birth of people killing each
other's children
depending on what kind of Christian they
were and sending each other's children
in rhetoric to hell but savage says that
argument is flawed the conflict in
Northern Ireland which he'd actually
personally observed kind of omitting or
or overlooking at least you know really
the the central element in the Northern
Irish conflict which was British
involvement in Northern Ireland there's
one other thing we need to highlight in
this debate about religious violence the
number of conflicts that haven't
involved religion at all if you ask the
question who has killed more people in
the last hundred years Muslims or
atheists the answer is atheists and and
it's not even close let's sit for one
the most infamous ones of our time the
palestinian-israeli conflict which
allegedly pits Muslims against Jews but
how true is that statement Jewish
atheist led the Zionist movement that
created the State of Israel they argued
for a Jewish nation state as a response
to European anti-semitism meanwhile
Muslim and Christian Palestinians live
under Israeli occupation in the West
Bank and Gaza and protests Israeli
efforts to claim Jerusalem together it's
not hard to see how Israel's
displacement of and occupation over the
indigenous Palestinian population rather
than the differences of faith are the
sources of the strife and here's what
Hitchens said shortly before his death
in 2011 on the conflict because of the
divine promises made about this
territory there will never be peace they
will not be compromised they will
instead be misery I think that religious
ideas are often used to legitimize
violence I think often a more useful
framework for thinking about you know
the sources of conflict is nationalism
there's one more example than New
Atheists
often used to make their anti religion
points Isis Isis is the militant group
that took over parts of Iraq and Syria
spreading its violent messianic version
of Islamic faith the group killed all
who stood in its path whether they were
Sunni she Christian or otherwise Isis is
behaving in a way that is sanctioned by
a literal reading of the Koran and the
hadith but Isis and Islam may not be as
closely aligned as Harris presents I
can't think of a better illustration of
this
than the two young men they were from
Birmingham and they went to join the
Islamic state and they quite literally
bought a copy of Islam for dummies from
Amazon before they left
Isis's creation is a side effect of the
2003 US invasion of Iraq which created a
political and security vacuum that
allowed such groups to flourish
according to savage it's pretty common
for people to look at conflicts and tie
them to some ancient disagreement
instead of Western military involvement
which actually creates those modern
conflicts new atheists emerge after the
September 11 2001 attacks in the United
States and have consistently attacked
Islam I regard Islam as one of the great
evils in the world
the idea that Islam is inherently
violent is a really widespread idea
that's not just limited to the New
Atheists
but they've given it a particularly
sharp polemical edge in 2017 a Pew
Research Center study found that 41
percent of US adults believe that Islam
encourages violence more than other
faiths half also thought Islam was not a
part of mainstream American society with
44% saying that Islam and democracy are
incompatible but many new atheists
consider themselves true liberals or
guardians of liberal values in fact 69%
of the atheists in the u.s. leaned
democrat and are more likely to hold
liberal values yet the new atheist views
are liberal and that's why sam harris
and others believe there's a crisis of
liberalism because much of the left in
the US would criticize them what we're
seeing on the left is a kind of sensoria
sness and really kind of a Thorat Aryan
moment the New Atheists ridicule of
Islam has made them allies of the
neoconservative right the new atheist
affinities for the right and for the neo
cons in particular are really quite
explicit there are a lot of people who
are followers of new atheism that don't
entirely realize that you know the
politics of it are often rooted largely
on the right and might be appalled so
why is it so important to examine the
new atheist ideas well these guys are an
influential Bunch they've had books on
the New York Times bestseller lists and
they've had large platforms to broadcast
their ideas it's because the New
Atheists abrasive approach to religion
is seen as driving a wedge
between religious folks and
non-believing ones instead of finding
common ground so when influential people
like Sam Harris and Richard Dawkins make
statements like Islam is the mother lode
of bad ideas or I regard Islam as one of
the great evils in the world does that
make bigotry more acceptable in our
society I don't think there's any way to
kind of answer this in theory that
belief in God either does or doesn't
produce violence it all depends on the
context hey guys thanks for watching
hope you enjoyed the video please let us
know what you think in the comments I'm
sure the conversation is going to be
really lit this time come back next week
for another great video and don't forget
to Like share and subscribe